PATRICK DUBROY: Hi everybody,
my name's Patrick Dubroy and
today I'm going to talk
to you about memory
management for Android.
So I'm really happy to see so
many people here who care
about memory management,
especially near
the end of the day.
So let's get started.
So I'm sure you all remember
this device.
This is the T-Mobile G1.
Hugo talked about it in
the keynote yesterday.
It was released about two
and a half years ago.
So, is there anybody here who
actually developed on the G1?
All right, impressive.
That's about maybe
40% of the room.
So you may remember that
the G1 came with 192
megabytes of RAM.
And in fact, most of that was
used up by the system.
There wasn't a whole lot
left over for apps.
Fast forward a few years later,
we have the Motorola
Zoom released just a couple
of months ago.
The Zoom comes with
a gigabyte of RAM.
Now some people might hear
this and think, OK, my
troubles are over.
I never have to worry about
memory management again.
And of course, given that we
have a whole room here, you
guys are all smart people
and you realize
that that's not true.
And there are a couple
of reasons for this.
First of all, the Zoom has
six and a half times the
resolution that the G1 had.
So you've got six and
a half times as
many pixels on screen.
That means you're probably
going to
need to use more memory.
You got more bitmaps
for example.
The other thing is that on
tablets, you really want to
create a new kind
of application.
You know, the rich, immersive
applications, like this
YouTube app, for example.
These are going to take
a lot of memory.
There's tons of bitmaps
in here.
Those use up a lot of memory.
Also, the Zoom we're talking
about a pretty new device.
This is basically bleeding
edge hardware.
Most your customers are not
going to be using something
that's only two months old.
So of course, you want to
support people who are using
older hardware as well.
Finally, maybe you're all
familiar with Parkinson's Law,
which says that work always take
as much time as you have.
And really, it's kind of
the same for software.
So, no matter how much memory
you have, you're going to find
a way to use it and wish you
had just a little bit more.
What I want to talk about
today are basically two
different things.
First of all, I want to cover
some of the changes that we've
made in Gingerbread and
Honeycomb that affect how your
app uses memory.
That's your cameo.
All right, so as I was saying,
there are two different things
I want to cover today.
So first of all, I want to talk
about some of the changes
we've made in Gingerbread and
Honeycomb that affect how your
apps use memory.
And basically, memory management
in general.
In the second half of the talk
I want to talk about some
tools you can use to better
understand how your app is
using memory.
And if you have memory leaks,
how you can figure out where
those memory leaks are.
So just to set expectations for
this talk, I'm going to
make them some assumptions about
the stuff you've done
and it'll really help you get
the most out of this if you're
familiar with these concepts.
So I'm hoping that you've all
written Android apps before.
And it looked like about half
the room had developed on the
G1, so that's probably true.
I hope that most of you have
heard of the Dalvik heap.
You have a basic idea of what
I'm talking about when I talk
about heap memory.
I'm sure you're familiar with
the garbage collector.
You have a basic idea hopefully
of what garbage
collection is and
how it works.
And probably, most of you have
seen an OutOfMememoryError
before and you have a basic
idea of why you get it and
what you can do to
deal with it.
So first, let's talk
about heap size.
So you may know that in Android,
there's a hard limit
on your application's
heap size.
And there's a couple
reasons for this.
So first of all, one of the
great features of Android is
that it has full multitasking.
So you actually have multiple
programs running at once.
And so obviously, each
one can't use all of
your devices memory.
We also don't want a runaway
app to just start getting
bigger and bigger and bloating
the entire system.
You always want your dialer to
work, your launcher t work,
that sort of thing.
So there's this hard limit
on heap size and if your
application needs to allocate
more memory and you've gone up
to that heap size limit already,
then you're basically
going to get an out
of memory error.
So this heap size limit
is device dependent.
It's changed a lot
over the years.
On the G1 it was 16 megabytes.
On the Zoom it's now
48 megabytes.
So it's a little bit bigger.
If you're writing an app and you
want to know, OK, how much
heap space do I have
available?
You know, maybe you want to
decide how much stuff to keep
in a cache for example.
There's a method you can
use in ActivityManager,
getMemoryClass that will return
an integer value in
megabytes, which is
your heap size.
Now these limits were designed
assuming that you know almost
any app that you would want to
build on Android should be
able to fit under
these limits.
Of course, there are
some apps that are
really memory intensive.
And as I said, on the tablet, we
really want to build almost
a new class of application.
It's quite a different than the
kind of things you were
building on phones.
So we thought, if someone
wants to build an image
editor, for example, on
the Zoom, they should
be able to do that.
But an image editor's a really
memory intensive application.
It's unlikely that you could
build a good one that used
less than 48 megabytes
of heap.
So in Honeycomb we've added
a new option that allows
applications like this to
get a larger heap size.
Basically, , you can put
something in your
AndroidManifest, largeHeap
equals true.
And that will allow your
application to use more heap.
And similarly, there's a
method you can use to
determine how much memory you
have available to you.
The ActivityManager
getLargeMemoryClass method
again, will return an integer
value of this large heap size.
Now before we go any further,
I want to give
a big warning here.
You know, this is not something
you should be doing
just because you got an out of
memory error, or you think
that your app deserves
a bigger heap.
You're not going to be doing
yourself any favors because
your app is going to perform
more poorly because bigger
heap means you're going to spend
more time at garbage
collection.
Also, your users are probably
going to notice because all
their other apps are getting
kicked out of memory.
It's really something you want
to reserve for when you really
understand OK, I'm using tons
of memory and I know exactly
why I'm using that memory,
and I really
need to use that memory.
That's the only time that you
should be using this large
heap option.
So I mentioned garbage
collection.
And that it takes longer when
you have a bigger heap.
Let's talk a little bit about
garbage collection.
So I just want to go through a
quick explanation here of what
[INAUDIBLE]
garbage collection is doing.
So basically, you have
a set of objects.
First of all, let's say these
blue objects here, these are
the objects in your heap.
And they form a kind of graph.
They've got references
to each other.
Some of those objects are alive,
some of them are not
used anymore.
So what the GC does is it starts
from a set of objects
that we call the roots.
These are the objects that
the GC knows is alive.
For example, variables that are
alive on a thread stack, J
and I global references, we
treat objects in the zygote as
heap, or as roots as well.
So basically, the GC starts with
those objects and starts
visiting the other objects.
And basically, traversing
through the whole graph to
find out which objects are
referenced directly or
indirectly from the GC roots.
At the end of this process,
you've got some objects left
over, which the GC
never visited.
Those are your garbage.
They can be collected.
So it's a pretty
simple concept.
And you can see why when I
said that you have bigger
heaps you're going to have
larger pause times.
Because the garbage collector
basically has to traverse your
entire live set of objects.
If you're using say the large
heap option and you've got 256
megs of heap, well, that's a lot
of memory for the garbage
collector to walk over.
You're going to see longer
pause times with that.
We have some good news though.
In Gingerbread, there have been
some great changes to the
garbage collector that make
things a lot better.
So in Gingerbre--
sorry, pre-Gingerbread, the
state of the garbage collector
was that we had to stop
the world collector.
So what this means is that
basically, when a garbage
collection is in progress, your
application is stopped.
All your application threads are
completely stopped while
the collection is proceeding.
This is a pretty standard
things.
These pauses generally tend
to be pretty short.
What we found was that pause
times as heaps were getting
bigger, these were getting to
be a little bit too long.
So we were seeing stuff up
50 to 100 milliseconds.
And if you're trying to build
a really responsive app that
kind of pause time is not
really acceptable.
So in Gingerbread,
we now have a
concurrent garbage collector.
It does most of its work
concurrently, which means that
your application is not stopped
for the duration of
the garbage collection.
Basically, we have another
thread that's running at the
same time as your application
that can perform garbage
collection work.
You'll see basically
two short pauses.
One at the beginning
of a collection and
one near the end.
But these pause times are going
to be much, much lower.
Usually you'll see two, three,
four, or five milliseconds for
your pause time.
So that's a significant
improvement.
Pause times about 10% of
what they used to be.
So that's a really good change
that we have in Gingerbread.
Now if you're building memory
heavy apps, there's a good
chance you're using
a lot of bitmaps.
We found that in a lot of apps
you have maybe 50 or 75% of
your heap is taken
up by bitmaps.
And in Honeycomb because you're
going to be developing
on tablets, this gets
even worse.
Because your images are bigger
to fill the screen.
So before Honeycomb, the way we
managed bitmaps was this.
So the blue area up here is
the Dalvik heap and this
yellow object is a
bitmap object.
Now bitmap objects are always
the same size in the heap no
matter what their
resolution is.
The backing memory for the
bitmap is actually stored in
another object.
So the pixel data is
stored separately.
Now before Honeycomb what we
did was this pixel data was
actually native memory.
It was allocated using malloc
outside the Dalvik heap.
And this had a few
consequences.
If you wanted to free this
memory you could either call
recycle, which would free the
memory synchronously.
But if you didn't call recycle
and you were waiting for your
bitmap to get garbage collected,
we had to rely on
the finalizer to free the
backing memory for the bitmap.
And if you're familiar with
finalization, you probably
know that it's an inherently
unreliable process.
Just by its nature it takes
several collections, usually
for finalization to complete.
So this can cause problems with
bitmap heavy app as you
had to wait for several garbage
collections before
your pixel data was reclaimed.
And this could be a lot of
memory because bitmap pixel
data is quite a significant
portion of the heap.
This also made things
harder to debug.
If you were using standard
memory analysis tools like the
Eclipse Memory Analyzer, it
couldn't actually see this
native memory.
You would see this tiny
bitmap object.
Sure, but that doesn't
tell you very much.
You don't mind if you have
a 10 by 10 bitmap.
But if you have a 512 by 512
bitmap it's a big difference.
Finally, the other problem that
we had with this approach
was that it required full stop
the world garbage collections
in order to reclaim the backing
memory, assuming that
you didn't call recycle,
that is.
The good news is in Honeycomb
we've changed
the way this works.
And the bitmap pixel data is
now allocated inside the
Dalvik heap.
So this means it can be freed
synchronously by the GC on the
same cycle that your bitmap
gets collected.
It's also easier to debug
because you can see this
backing memory in standard
analysis tools like Eclipse
Memory Analyzer.
And I'm going to do a demo in
a few minutes and you'll see
really, how much more useful
this is when you
can see that memory.
Finally, this strategy is more
amenable to concurrent and
partial garbage collections,
which means we can generally
keep those pause times down.
So those are the two biggest
changes that we've introduced
in Gingerbread and Honeycomb
that affect how
your apps use memory.
And now I want to dive in to
some tools that you can use to
better understand how much
memory your app's using.
And if you have memory leaks,
better understanding where
those leaks are and generally,
how your app is using memory.
The most basic tool you can
use for understanding your
apps memory usage is to look
at your log messages.
So these are the log messages
that you see in DDMS in the
log cat view.
You can also see them
at the command line
using ADB log cat.
And every time a garbage
collection happens in your
process, you're going to see a
message that looks something
like this one.
And I just want to go through
the different parts of this
message, so you can better
understand what
it's telling you.
The first thing we have is the
reason for the garbage
collection.
Kind of what triggered it and
what kind of collection is it.
This one here was a concurrent
collection.
So a concurrent collection is
triggered by basically, as
your heap starts to fill up,
we kick off our concurrent
garbage collection so that it
can hopefully complete before
your heap gets full.
Other kinds of collections
that you'll
see in the log messages.
GC for malloc is one of them.
That's what happens when say,
we didn't complete the
concurrent collection in time
and your application had to
allocate more memory.
The heap was full, so we had
to stop and do a garbage
collection.
You'll see GC external alloc,
which is for externally
allocated memory, like
the bitmap pixel
data which I mentioned.
It's also used for NIO
direct byte buffers.
Now this external memory
as I mentioned, has
gone away in Honeycomb.
Basically everything
is allocated inside
the Dalvik heap now.
So you won't see this in
your log messages in
Honeycomb and later.
You'll also see a message if you
do an HPROF, if you create
an HPROF profile.
And finally, the last
one I want to
mention is GC explicit.
You'll see this generally when
you're calling system.gc,
which is something that
you know you really
should avoid doing.
In general, you should trust
in the garbage collector.
We've got some information
also about the amount of
memory that was freed
on this collection.
There's some statistics
about the heap.
So the heap in this case,
was 65% free after
the collection completed.
There's about three and a half
megs of live objects and the
total heap size here
is listed as well.
It's almost 10 megs, 9,991 K.
There's some information about
externally allocated memory,
which is the bitmap pixel
data and also,
NIO direct byte buffers.
The two numbers here, the first
number is the amount of
external memory that your
app has allocated.
The second number is a
sort of soft limit.
When you've allocated that much
memory, we're going to
kick off a GC.
Finally, you'll see the pause
times for that collection.
And this is where you're
going to see the effect
of your heap size.
Larger heaps are going to
have larger pause times.
The good news is for a
concurrent collection, you're
going to see these pause times
generally pretty low.
Concurrent collections are going
to show two pause times.
There's one short pause at the
beginning of the collection
and one most of the
way through.
Non-concurrent collections
you'll see a single pause
time, and this is generally
going to
be quite a bit higher.
So looking at your log messages
is a really basic way
to understand how much memory
your app is using.
But it doesn't really
tell you, where am
I using that memory?
What objects are using
this memory?
And the best way to do that
is using heap dumps.
So a heap dump is basically a
binary file that contains
information about all of the
objects in your heap.
You can create a heap dump using
DDMS by clicking on the
icon, this somewhat
cryptic icon.
I think [INAUDIBLE]
mentioned it in the
previous talk.
There's also an API for
creating heap dumps.
In general, I find using
DDMS is fine.
There are times when you want
to create a heap dump at a
very, very specific
point in time.
Maybe when you're trying to
track down a memory leak.
So it can be helpful
to use that API.
You may need to convert the
heap dump to the standard
HPROF format.
You'll only need to do that if
you're using the standalone
version of DDMS. If you're using
the Eclipse plug-in, the
ADT plug-in, it will
automatically convert it.
But the conversion
is pretty simple.
There's a tool in the Android
SDK, which you
can use to do it.
And after you've converted it to
the standard HPROF format,
you can analyze it with standard
heap analysis tools,
like MAT or jhat.
And I'm going to show an example
of MAT, which is the
shorter way of saying the
Eclipse Memory Analyzer.
And before I jump into the demo,
I want to talk about
memory leaks.
So there's kind of a
misconception that in a
managed run time, you can't
have memory leaks.
And I'm sure you guys know
that's not true.
Having a garbage collector does
not prevent memory leaks.
A memory leak in a managed run
time is a little bit different
though, than a memory
leak in C or C++.
Basically, a leak is when you
have a reference to an unused
object that's preventing
that object from
being garbage collected.
And sometimes you can have a
reference to a single object,
but that object points to a
bunch of other objects.
And basically, that single
reference is preventing a
large group of objects
from being collected.
One thing to watch out
for in Android.
I see people sometimes and
I've done this myself,
accidentally create a memory
leak by holding a long lived
reference to an activity.
So you need to be really careful
with that and maybe
it's you're holding a reference
to the context and
that's what happens.
You can also do it by keeping
a long lived reference to a
view or to a drawable, because
these will also hold a
reference to the activity that
they were originally in.
And the reason that this is
a problem, the reason this
causes a memory leak is this.
So you've got your activity,
it contains a view group, a
linear layout or something, and
it contains some views.
And we've got a reference from
the framework to the currently
visible activity.
But in Android, when you have
a rotation event, so you
rotate your device, what we do
is actually build up a new
view hierarchy because you need
to load new resources,
you may have a brand new
layout for landscape or
portrait, you may
have differently
sized icons or bitmaps.
And then we basically remove the
reference to the old view
hierarchy and point
to the new one.
And the idea is that this old
view hierarchy sure get
garbage collected.
But if you're holding a
reference to that, you're
going to prevent it from getting
garbage collected.
And that's why it's a problem
to hold the long lived
reference to an activity or
even to a view because in
fact, the arrows connecting
these objects should be going
in both directions.
Because you've got pointers
all the way up.
So if you do have a memory leak,
a really good way to
figure out where it
is is using the
Eclipse Memory Analyzer.
I'm going to do a demo of that,
but I want to first
cover some of the concepts
behind the Memory Analyzer, so
that when I do the demo you'll
better understand what I'm
showing you.
So the Eclipse Memory Analyzer
can be downloaded from the
eclipse.org site.
It comes in a couple
of flavors.
There's an Eclipse plug-in
version, there's also a
standalone version.
I'm going to be demonstrating
the standalone version.
I just personally prefer not to
have Eclipse have all these
different plug-ins.
I kind of like to keep things
a little bit separate.
But they're basically
the same.
Now, Memory Analyzer has some
important concepts that
you'll see a lot.
It talks about shallow heap
and retained heap.
So the shallow heap of an object
is just how large is
this object, it's
size and bytes.
It's really simple.
So let's say that all of these
objects are 100 bytes.
So they're shallow heap
is 100 bytes.
It's easy.
The retained heap is something
different.
Basically, the retained heap
says, if I have an object here
and I were to free this object,
what other objects is
it pointing to?
And could those be freed
at the same time?
And so you calculate the
retained heap in terms of,
what is the total size of
objects that could be freed by
freeing this one object?
So maybe it's best to understand
with an example.
So this object down on the
right-hand side in yellow,
this guy doesn't point
to any other objects.
So his retained size is pretty
easy to calculate.
His retained heap is 100.
This guy on top, he has a
pointer to one other object.
But he's not holding
that object alive.
There are other pointers
to that same object.
So this guy's retained heap
is also just 100 bytes.
Because if we were to remove
this object, it's not going to
free up any other objects.
The object down at the end
however, it's basically
keeping all the other
objects alive.
So its retained heap is 400
because if we could free that
object, we could free all the
other objects well, on this
slide anyway.
So you might be wondering, how
do you go about calculating
the retain heap?
So you're going to see this
in Memory Analyzer.
And actually, knowing how it
calculates the retained heap
is quite useful.
So the Memory Analyzer
uses a concept called
the denominator tree.
This is a concept from
graph theory.
Basically, if you have a node
A and a node B, A is said to
be the dominator of B if every
path to B goes through A.
And so you might see how that
could help us figure out what
the retained heap
of an object is.
So another example here.
So let's start with A.
It's kind of the root.
B and C are only accessible
through A.
So it's pretty straightforward.
They're children of A and
the dominator tree.
E is also only accessible
through C.
So it's a child of C in
the dominator tree.
D is a little bit interesting
here.
D can be accessed through
B or C, but A is on
every path to D.
So that means that A is
the parent of D and
the dominator tree.
And now you're going to see this
dominator tree concept
also pop up in Memory
Analyzer in its UI.
And it can be really
helpful for
tracking down memory leaks.
So let's jump in and do a
demo of debugging and
memory leak with MAT.
So what I'm going to use for
this demo is the Honeycomb
gallery's sample application.
It's a simple application that
comes with the Android SDK the
basically just demonstrates
some of
the features of Honeycomb.
And really, all it is is a
little app the lets you page
through some photos.
Pretty simple.
Now I've done something
kind of naughty here.
I've introduced a memory leak
into this application.
And I'll show you how
I've done that.
Sorry, I better switch
to the slides again.
So you'll see here I have the
source code, an excerpt of the
source code from the activity.
And so what I've done here is
I've introduced this inner
class called leaky.
And this is not a static
inner class.
So you may know that if you
create a non-static inner
class, it actually keeps
a reference to
the enclosing object.
And this is because from a
non-static inner class, you
can actually refer to the
instance variables of the
enclosing object.
So it's going to retain
a reference to
the activity here.
That's fine as long as this
object doesn't live longer
than the activity.
But I've got this static field
and statics live longer than
any particular instance.
And in my on create method, what
I've done is instantiated
the leaky object and stored
it into the static field.
So if you want to be able to
visualize this, I basically
got my view hierarchy that
starts with the main activity.
I've instantiated this leaky
object and he has a reference
to the main activity because
that was its enclosing class.
Finally, I have the main
activity class, which is
conceptually a different
area of memory than
any particular instance.
And there's a static variable
pointing to the leaky object.
So maybe you can see how this
is going to cause a memory
leak when I rotate the screen.
So let's jump in and take a
look at this memory leak.
So if you want to figure out
whether you have a memory
leak, one of the easiest ways
is to just kind of look at
your log messages.
So I'm just going to do that.
I'm going to do it at
the command line.
I can just type ADB log cat.
And I want to restrict it to
the particular process that
I've got running here.
I don't want to see all of the
log messages on the system.
So I'm just going to grab
on the process ID.
There we see a bunch a log
messages, including some
garbage collection messages.
And the number you want to look
at is basically the first
number here in the 9805K.
The first number in
your heap size.
This is the amount of live
objects in the system.
And if you're looking for a
memory leak, that's what you
want to look at.
So I'm going to flip through
some of the photos here.
And you'll see that that number
stays pretty constant.
We're up to 9872.
But basically, the heap usage
is pretty constant.
Now when I rotate this device,
we're going to be a bunch of
garbage collections happen.
That heap usage goes up and
it doesn't go down again.
So we're now up to
12 megs of heap.
So we leaked about two
and a half megs.
So whenever you see your memory
go up in kind of a step
function like that, it steps
up and just never goes back
down, that's a good sign
you have a memory leak.
So once you know that you have a
leak, what you'll want to do
is create a heap dump, so you
can go about debugging it.
So I'm going to do
that right now.
I'll open up DDMS.
You just need to select the
process that you care about
and click on this icon up in
the toolbar that says dump
HPROF file.
That'll create a heap dump.
It takes a few seconds because
it's dumping basically a huge
binary file out to disk.
And then I can just save it in
a file called dump.hprof.
And then, because I'm using
this standalone version of
DDMS here, I need to
convert this file.
As I mentioned, if you're using
the ADT plug-in for
Eclipse and using DDMS in there,
you don't need to go
through this conversion step.
But it's really simple.
Now that I've converted it, I
can open up the Eclipse Memory
Analyzer and take a look
at this heap dump.
So there's not much to see in
the Memory Analyzer until
you've opened up a heap dump,
which we can do just
from the file menu.
Open heap dump.
And I'll open up this converted
heap dump, which I
just created.
Doesn't take very long
for it to load up.
And the first thing you'll
see is this pie chart.
This is showing the biggest
objects in the system by
retained size.
Now this alone doesn't really
tell us too much.
You can see that down in the
bottom left here, when I mouse
over the various slices of the
pie, it's telling me what kind
of object I've got.
But that doesn't really
tell us too much.
If we want to get some more
information, you want
to look down here.
There are two views.
The histogram view and
the dominator tree.
And these are the ones that I
find most useful and I'm going
to show to you.
Let's take a look at
the dominator tree.
You remember the concept
I explained.
This is how it can be
useful in tracking
down a memory leak.
So what we've got here is
basically a list of instances
or a list of objects in
this system organized.
There's a column here.
Organized by the amount
of retained heap.
So when you've got a memory
leak, looking at the amount of
retained heap is often a good
way to look at things because
that's going to have the biggest
effect on how much
memory you're using.
And chances are, if you've
noticed that you've got a
leak, you're leaking a
significant amount.
So let me just zoom in here.
Hopefully you guys can see
this a bit better.
So at the very top of the list
we have the resources class.
That's not too surprising
because our resources we have
to load lots of bitmaps.
That's going to hold lots
of memory alive.
That's fine.
These two bitmap objects
are interesting.
I've got these two large
bitmaps, more than two and a
half megs each.
It's funny because that sounds
about like the amount of
memory that I was leaking.
So if I want to investigate a
bit further, I can right click
on one of these objects and
choose path to GC roots.
And I'll chose excluding weak
references because I want to
see what's keeping that
object alive.
And a weak reference is not
going to keep it alive.
So this opened up a new tab
and what do you know?
It actually points
right to my leak.
So when you're creating leaks in
your application, make sure
you name it something really
helpful like this so you can
find it easily.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
PATRICK DUBROY: So some of you
might have noticed this, that
if there's only a single path to
this object, because that's
all I can see here, why didn't
this leak object show up in
the dominator tree?
I mentioned that the dominator
tree should show you the
largest objects by their amount
of retained heap.
And well this is a single object
that's responsible for
retaining the bitmap.
So the reason for that is that
the Eclipse Memory Analyzer,
when it calculates the dominator
tree, it actually
doesn't treat weak references
separately.
It basically just treats them
like a normal reference.
So you'll see that if I actually
right click on this
guy again and say path to GC
roots, and say with all
references, then there's
actually another
path to this object.
But it's a weak reference.
Generally you don't need to be
too concerned about weak
references because they're not
going to prevent your object
from being garbage collected.
But that's why the leak object
didn't show up in the
dominator tree.
So the dominator tree is one
really, really useful way of
tracking down a memory leak.
Another thing I like to use
is the histogram view.
So I mentioned that in Android,
it's common to leak
memory by keeping long lived
references to an activity.
So you may want to actually
go and look at the number
instances of your main activity
class that you have.
And the histogram view
lets you do that.
So the histogram view just
shows a list of all the
classes in its system and right
now it's sorted based on
the amount of shallow
heap occupied by
classes in the system.
So at the very top there, we
see we have byte arrays.
And the reason for this is that
byte arrays are now the
backing memory for pixel data.
And you know, this is a perfect
example of why it's
really useful that we
now have the pixel
data inside the heap.
Because if you're using this
on Gingerbread or earlier,
you're not going to see byte
arrays at the top.
Because that memory with
allocated in native memory.
So we could also, if we were
concerned about these byte
array objects, we might want to
right click on it and say
list objects with incoming
references.
And we've got our two large
byte array objects here.
We can right click on one and
say, path to GC roots,
excluding weak references.
So this guy looks to
have several paths,
which keep it alive.
Nothing looks out of
the ordinary to me.
And when you're trying to find
a memory leak, there's not
really a magic answer for
how you find a leak.
You really have to understand
your system and understand
what objects are alive, why
they're alive, during the
various parts of your
application.
But you'll see if I look at this
other byte array object,
and again, do path to GC roots
excluding weak references,
well, I've found
my leak again.
So this was another way that I
might have found this if it
weren't so obvious from
the dominator tree.
The histogram view can
also help us look for
our activity instances.
So there's a lot of classes
obviously in the system.
Our activity is not here.
There's 2,200 classes.
But luckily, Eclipse Memory
Analyzer has this handy little
filter view at the top.
You can just start typing
a regular expression.
And it'll return you all the
classes that match that.
So here we've got our
main activity.
And it tells us that there are
actually two instances of this
main activity.
And that should kind
of be a red flag.
Normally you should expect to
see only a single instance of
your main activity alive.
Now I mentioned during the
screen rotation, we build up a
new view hierarchy, there's
going to be a brief time where
there's two instances alive.
But for the most part, you
should expect to see one here.
So I might think, OK,
this is a red flag.
Let's take a look.
So I can right click on this
object and list objects with
incoming references.
So I want to look at what
instances do I have and what's
pointing to them?
And so I've got two
instances here.
If I right click on one of them
and choose path to GC
roots, excluding weak
references, I've again, found
my memory leak.
And in looking at this, I might
realize that, oh, I
really didn't intend
to do this.
I didn't mean to keep this
reference there.
So that's another way that you
could have found the leak.
So now that we've discovered
where our memory leak is, why
don't we actually go
ahead and fix it.
So in this case, the problem was
that we had a non-static
inner class.
So we could fix this by making
it a static inner class.
And then it wouldn't actually
keep a reference to the
enclosing activity.
The other thing we could do is
actually just not store it in
a static variable.
So it's fine if this leaky
object has a reference to the
activity, as long as
it doesn't live
longer than the activity.
So let's do that.
Let's just make this
a regular instance
variable and not a static.
So then I can go in here
recompile this and push it to
the device.
And hopefully, we should see
that our memory leak has been
eliminated.
Sorry, what we actually want
to do is look at our log
output in order to see how
much memory we're using.
So I'm just going to fire up the
process here, take a look
at the process ID.
And again, just do ADP log
cat just on that process.
So as I page through the photos
again, we see lots of
GC messages.
When I rotate, we're going to
see the memory usage goes up
for a minute there.
But after a few collections,
it does go back down to its
previous value.
So we've successfully eliminated
the leak there.
And this is great.
You always want to eliminate
memory leaks.
So that's an example of using
the Eclipse Memory Analyzer to
debug a memory leak.
Eclipse Memory Analyzer is
a really powerful tool.
It's a little bit complex.
It actually took me quite a
while to figure out that these
were the two best tools
for the job.
So you really want to watch out
for these memory leaks.
So I gave an example here of
retaining a long lived
reference to an activity.
If you've got our context, a
view, a drawable, all of these
things you need to
watch out for.
Don't hold long lived
references to those.
It can also happen with
non-static inner classes,
which is what I demonstrated
there as well.
Runnable is actually one that
can bite you sometimes.
You know, you create
a new runnable.
You have a deferred event that's
going to run in like
five minutes.
If user rotates the screen
that deferred runnable is
going to hold your previous
activity instance alive for
five minutes.
So that's not good.
You also want to watch
out for caches.
Sometimes you have a cache and
you want to keep memory alive,
so that you can load images
faster let's say.
But you may inadvertently hold
things alive too long.
So that covers basically, the
core parts of the Eclipse
Memory Analyzer, and gives you
a basic understanding of
memory leaks.
If you'd like to get more
information about Memory
Analyzer, the download link
you can find on the
eclipse.org/mat site.
Markus Kohler who's one of the
original team members of
Eclipse Memory Analyzer, he
has a blog called the Java
Performance Blog.
This is really great.
He's got tons of great articles
on there about MAT
and different ways you can
use it to understand your
applications memory usage.
I've also got an article that
I wrote on the Android
Developer Blog called memory
analysis for Android
applications.
It covers a lot of the
same stuff that I
did in my demo here.
And Romain Guy also has a good
article on avoiding memory
leaks in Android.
So I hope that's been helpful,
I hope you guys have a better
understanding now of how you
can figure out your apps
memory usage.
And I've talked about two of the
biggest changes that we've
made in Gingerbread and
Honeycomb that affect how your
apps use memory.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
So I can take questions from the
floor if anyone has any.
Or you all want to get out and
get to a pub and have a beer?
AUDIENCE: Hi, you mentioned
that if you use NIO in
Honeycomb your objects are
going to be not in native
memory and now they're going
to be managed memory.
How does that affect performance
if you're doing an
IO, is that going to
be any slower, like
very intense on network?
PATRICK DUBROY: No, I mean
it shouldn't affect.
So I should say that there is
still a way to allocate native
memory for your NIO
byte buffers.
I'm not that familiar with the
NIO APIs, but I believe
there's a way in JNI you can
allocate your own memory.
So in that case, you'll still
be using native memory.
But either way, it's
just memory.
It's just allocated in
a different place.
So there's nothing that makes
the Dalvik heap memory slower
than other memory.
AUDIENCE: So you're saying how
in Honeycomb the bitmaps are
stored in the Dalvik heap, but
in previous versions to that
it was stored on
native memory.
Does that mean that bitmaps
had a different
amount of heap size?
Or is that still all counted in
the 16 or 24 megabytes that
previous versions had?
PATRICK DUBROY: Yeah,
good question.
The accounting limits
are still the same.
That was accounted
for previously.
You might have noticed if you
ever ran into your heap limit,
you would be looking at your
heap size and like, I haven't
hit the limit yet, why am I'm
getting out of memory?
That was actually accounted for,
so it was your total heap
size plus the amount of
externally allocated memory
that was your limit.
So that hasn't changed.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I have a question on when
does the garbage
collector kicks in.
Is is when a number of
objects in memory or
the size of the heap?
PATRICK DUBROY: Well, it
depends on what kind of
garbage collection you're
talking about.
The concurrent garbage
collector--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, the
concurrent.
Yes.
PATRICK DUBROY: Yeah, so that
I believe is the amount of
basically, how full your
heap is getting.
AUDIENCE: Because I noticed
that when you do a lot of
[INAUDIBLE]
provide operations, so you
have like [INAUDIBLE]
list of operations, the garbage
collector kicks in.
But actually don't collect any
objects because you're just
filling in the array of objects
that you want to
insert into a database.
And that's grow quite quickly.
And that tends to slow down a
bit, the application without
actually solving
any heap size.
PATRICK DUBROY: Yeah, I'm not
sure if the GC looks at--
so you're basically saying, I
guess, that the collector is
kicking in.
It's not actually able to
collect anything, so it
shouldn't--
AUDIENCE: But it keeps trying.
PATRICK DUBROY: Yeah, it
should be smart enough.
Yeah, I don't believe we
actually look at those kind of
statistics yet.
But I mean it seems
reasonable.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering if you
guys have some plans for
making a profiler for
applications or more tools for
analyzing memory and
all that stuff?
PATRICK DUBROY: No plans
that I know of.
Is there anything in particular
that you need?
I mean I think the Eclipse
Memory Analyzer is a really
powerful tool and I use
it in my day-to-day
work quite a bit.
So I've certainly never found
that it it was missing certain
features that I needed.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, probably because
there are some old
versions from Android that show
memory leaks or something.
But for example, on
Eclair, there were
some stuff with the--
something there.
PATRICK DUBROY: Yeah, I mean
we don't have any immediate
plans I don't think to running
specific tools.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
PATRICK DUBROY: Oh,
sorry I've been--
yeah.
AUDIENCE: To my understanding,
the native part of a bitmap
memory before was actually an
instance of the SKIA library,
of one of the SKIA library
bitmap classes.
So is this still there or is it
gone now that there is no
more native memory allocated?
PATRICK DUBROY: No,
SKIA is still part
of this stack there.
Basically at the point where
SKIA calls out to allocate
memory, we actually just call
back into the VM and allocate
the memory there rather
than calling malloc.
So it's still basically the
same mechanism, but the
memory's just coming from
a different place.
AUDIENCE: OK.
AUDIENCE: I thought that when I
was using my application, I
checked the heap size.
While using the application
the heap size was not
significantly going up.
But the amount of memory used
by the application, which is
listed in the applications tab
under the running applications
is going up significantly.
Sometimes even doubling.
I know that this is
a different heap
that is shown there.
It's actually the process
heap, right?
Can you tell me what the
background of that is that
this is shown there because
might like--
I don't have a memory leak and
users complain about my
application leaking memory.
Because for the user it looks
like it's leaking memory.
PATRICK DUBROY: Right.
Because you're saying there's
stuff that's attributed to
your process that are
showing up in the--
basically, in system memory?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So it's showing the system
memory in the applications
tab, which is not really linked
to my heap memory.
So that is going up, but I can
only control the heap memory.
If I don't have a native
application I cannot control
everything else.
PATRICK DUBROY: I mean there are
going to be various things
in the system that are
going to get larger.
For example, like your
JIT code caches.
As the JIT kicks in and is
allocating memory, like it
needs to store the compiled
code somewhere.
So there's definitely other
parts of this system that
allocate memory that's going to
kind of get charged to your
application.
But I can't think of why.
I can't think of anything that
would be out of the ordinary
really that should
cause problems.
AUDIENCE: But do you know if
this will be changed maybe in
the future?
That this number is not shown
there because for me, it
doesn't make sense to show this
number to the end user
because he doesn't understand
what it means.
PATRICK DUBROY: I see.
Where is he seeing the number?
AUDIENCE: In the running
applications tab.
If he goes to settings, running
applications, he can
see the memory usage per
application and that's
actually the system memory.
PATRICK DUBROY: I see.
Yeah, I'm not sure what our
plans are with that.
Sorry.
I can take a look and I'm not
actually sure where it's
getting that number from.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
AUDIENCE: My question's about
reasonable expectations of out
of memory errors.
Is it possible to completely
eliminate them?
We've been working for a while
in getting rid of all the out
of memory errors and down
to one in about
every 17,000 sessions.
Should we keep troubleshooting.
I mean, I'd like to get it
down to zero, but is that
reasonable or?
PATRICK DUBROY: So there are
certain scenarios where if
you're really close to your
memory limit, so if your
applications live memory size is
really close to that limit,
the garbage collector's
fundamentally kind of
asynchronous.
So if you're really close to the
limit, there can be times
where you're just trying to
allocate so fast that the
garbage collector
can't keep up.
So you can be actually
sort of out
running the garbage collector.
So certainly it's possible to
build applications that never
see an out of memory error.
But on the other hand, there
are certain types of
applications that are going to
be running really, really
close to the limits.
One thing you can use if you
have caches or things that you
can free up, there are several
ways to figure out that you're
getting close to the
heap memory limit.
I believe there's a callback you
can get notification that
we're getting low on memory.
Although, the name escapes me.
But you can also look at that,
the Activity Manager, get
memory class to get a sense of
how much memory you have
available on the system.
And you know, maybe you can keep
like smaller caches or
leave the initialize objects
rather than initializing them
all in the constructor or
something like that.
It really depends on the
application whether you expect
to be running close to that
heap limit or not.
AUDIENCE: You recommended not to
call system.gc manually if
you can help it.
Is there any way to reliably
free bitmap memory
pre-Honeycomb?
PATRICK DUBROY: Yes.
Pre-Honeycomb?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PATRICK DUBROY: You can call
recycle on the bitmap.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, but it can
still take several passes
apparently.
PATRICK DUBROY: No.
If you call recycle that
will immediately
free the backing memory.
The bitmap itself, that's like
80 bytes or something.
AUDIENCE: There are also bitmaps
like drawables that
you can't manually recycle the
bitmaps that the drawable
object creates.
PATRICK DUBROY: OK.
AUDIENCE: The backing
bitmaps for those.
PATRICK DUBROY: I see.
No, I mean there are still
some cases I guess where
system.gc is the
right approach.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
PATRICK DUBROY: OK, which
objects are you
talking about in--
AUDIENCE: My experience is when
I have image drawables
that are used some where in my
layout and I know they're no
longer needed.
Some of them are fairly large
and it seems like--
PATRICK DUBROY: You can call
recycle on those I believe.
AUDIENCE: OK.
My experience is that
it will cause other
problems when I do that.
PATRICK DUBROY: If you're
still using
them, then you can't--
I mean, you can only recycle
that when you're not using it.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
OK.
AUDIENCE: For native code that
uses a lot of mallocs, what's
the best way to manage
that memory?
PATRICK DUBROY: That's
a very good question.
When you've got native code,
I mean mostly what I was
covering here was managing
memory from the
Dalvik side of things.
I don't know that I have
any real pointers.
I mean that's one of the reasons
why programming in a
managed run time is very nice.
Is that you don't have
to deal with manually
managing your memory.
I don't have any great
advice for that.
AUDIENCE: Does the app that
calls into the native
libraries, is it aware of, at
least on an aggravate level,
how much memory is being
used or is it
completely a separate--
PATRICK DUBROY: I don't believe
there's any way to
account for if you're calling
into the library and it's
calling malloc.
I don't know that there's any
way to account for that memory
from your application side.
AUDIENCE: But that garbage
collector will run when you
start allocating memory,
will it not?
PATRICK DUBROY: It'll run when
you start allocating like
objects in Dalvik.
It doesn't have any knowledge
of calls to malloc.
AUDIENCE: You'll just get an
out of memory or a failed
malloc if you--
PATRICK DUBROY: Yeah.
Sure.
It's going to be the
same mechanisms as
any C or C++ program.
Malloc is going to return
a null pointer.
Yes?
AUDIENCE:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
PATRICK DUBROY: Pardon me?
AUDIENCE:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
PATRICK DUBROY: Oh, OK.
That's news to me.
Malloc can't fail on Android.
AUDIENCE:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
PATRICK DUBROY: I see.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Can you repeat that?
PATRICK DUBROY: Romain
tells me that malloc
can't fail on Android.
AUDIENCE:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
PATRICK DUBROY: I see.
So I think this is the
old Linux lazy--
yeah.
It'll successfully allocate the
virtual memory, but Linux
can actually hand out more
virtual memory than it can
actually commit.
So you can get problems. Like
when your system is totally,
totally out of native memory,
you're going to see crashes.
AUDIENCE: So native memory is
completely separate from
anything Dalvik?
PATRICK DUBROY: Yes.
Well, I mean, sorry, I should
say, like Dalvik is still
allocating its own memory like
for the heap through the
native mechanisms. So it's
reserving the same virtual
memory pages that other
applications are using.
AUDIENCE: But if your
system memory is--
PATRICK DUBROY: Yeah, if your
system memory is out, you're
in trouble.
AUDIENCE: But Dalvik won't get
a notice say, hey, better
start garbage collecting?
PATRICK DUBROY: Well, no.
AUDIENCE: The flag for using
larger heap, does that require
a permission, like users
permission or
something like that?
PATRICK DUBROY: I can't
remember whether we
added that or not.
I don't think that it does.
AUDIENCE: Like the whole--
could it been like a
permission thing?
But if it's not then--
PATRICK DUBROY: Yeah, I mean
the idea I think is that--
yeah, you're right.
I mean it can affect the system
as a whole because
you're going to have apps that
are using a lot more memory,
which is why I gave that big
warning, that this is not
something that you should be
using unless you know that you
really need it.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
But [INAUDIBLE].
OK.
PATRICK DUBROY: I don't
think there's a
permission for it, though.
AUDIENCE: What if the app kind
of runs in the background for
weeks at a time?
So I do everything I can to
simulate a leak, click
everywhere I can, but I see the
leaks if the app runs two
or three days and then
I get [INAUDIBLE].
PATRICK DUBROY: One thing you
could try is if you can use
the APIs to determine how much
free memory you have. I don't
know if there's any way you can
actually kind of notice in
your application that
it started leaking.
But you could write out an HPROF
file when you notice
that you've gotten to a certain
point, your heap is
getting smaller and smaller.
So there is some debug
information there
that you could use.
So if you have like some beta
testers, who could actually
send you these dumps, then
you could do that.
So write out the HPROF file
to SD card or something.
AUDIENCE: So maybe I can just
write an HPROF file every--
PATRICK DUBROY: I wouldn't
do that.
I mean they're quite large.
You don't want to be doing
that on a regular basis.
But if you detect that things
have gone really, really wrong
and you're about to die, in an
alpha version or something for
testing that's one way
you could do it.
But I definitely wouldn't
recommend putting an app in
the market that's dumping like
very large files to the SD
card for no reason.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PATRICK DUBROY: OK,
thanks a lot.